[Applause]
[Music]
hello
and welcome to the first episode in a
long while
of black man beyond my name is mark
bernard uh the other guy who would be
here who would allow us to call us fat
man beyond
is in new jersey i i think you know you
all are well aware of what mr smith is
up to he's not gone to washington he's
gone to leonardo
to make clerks three i was i was there
this weekend
um doing i don't know eating friggin
pizza and bagels and
good jersey food
and you know i i i got to say hello
um and i won't say that i did anything
more than that for fear of
um prodding the gods of security to keep
things clamped down i'm not going to be
that guy
so um all of which is to say for the
next couple of weeks um before he
returns which i think should be
mid-september um you'll get me
you'll get this face there may be other
faces with me um there may not it's
unclear i know for sure that rahul kohli
is going to be joining me on the 31st
um
uh at scrum and villain i'm going to do
it live so if you want to come come on
down you know go to seesmod.com um and
get yourself some shiny ass tickets um
there will be things to give away
lots of things to give away um
it's a very cool [ __ ] to give away um
and also you get to hang out in a cool
space bar and drink cool space bar
drinks and uh and listen to me
not be as charming as uh as rahul is so
yeah do come down
but that's not why we're here today not
here today to plug anything um i'm here
there there are ads to be read later but
i'm here to
fulfill a debt um some might call it a
life debt some might call it um
a blood bond that has been incurred
when uh when i started the the
kickstarter for my short film splinter
um
many of you have been here for the story
i did not expect it to do anything i
expected it to to come up woefully short
and that i would be dragging ass over
the finish line trying my best to raise
enough money to make this movie and
thanks to many of you in the chat we did
extraordinarily well extraordinarily
quickly
um but as we began you know continuing
with it with the kickstarter campaign we
started offering up some stretch goals
um and one of them was if we made a
certain amount of money
i would after having reviewed zack
snyder's justice league before um and uh
and feeling a certain way about it if
you want to revisit that you can it's in
the feed in both audio and video and so
if you want to see how both kevin and i
felt about it you can
but that i would revisit this the slider
cut
and only talk about the things that i
liked
um
i'm i'm calling it the the bright side
edition of my review um so that that is
why we're here that is why we've
gathered here today uh to talk about
these things um
i think called life
but before we get to that
um i am going to uh i'm going to read an
ad for uh for a little smell good juicy
juice
and then we're going to talk about a
couple of things we're going to go like
descending order of newness
in this episode so we're going to read
an ad we're going to talk a little bit
about the spider-man from home trailer
we're going to talk a little bit about
the suicide squad the suicide squad not
the not lowercase the uppercase they
and uh and then we're going to get into
the justice league
is that sound cool with you guys is that
um would that be okay for a tuesday
afternoon slash early evening of
shenanigans uh with your friend mark
i'm that guy um and also jc is here even
though he's he's hiding in the ether um
if he wants to oh
he he didn't even ban fan like we saved
the bombs for when the big man is back
um now he just like slides into the back
door
slides in through the back door yeah it
does um
all right so yeah before we go any
further
native deo we have talked quite a bit
about native deo on this podcast um and
i'm sure you've also heard the the long
and luxurious stories of how uh
jen schwalbach mrs kevin smith is the
biggest fan of native deo so much so
that she buys it without even waiting
for the magic box of goodies to show up
at kev's house um
but native deo
is uh is why stink if you don't have to
stink like there's plenty of things in
the world that stinks um most
of
current events kind of stinks most of
the last two years kind of stinks you
don't have to though because native deo
cares about the products you put on your
body they're about stopping the sting
the right way that's the native
difference you probably already know
from a number of times we've told you
about their legendary aluminum free
deodorant aluminium free if you're
british but if you tried their body wash
toothpaste or their brand new mineral
based sunscreen
bruh i got a broad spectrum spf 30
sunscreen for your face and body
lightweight absorbs quickly you can
choose between unscented or coconut and
pineapple they're on a mission to
overhaul your entire hygiene routine
that rhymes
by putting the care and self-care with
products carefully made to work against
odor that are made with simple
ingredients and smell great everybody's
different everybody's body will react to
this differently so if there's one
fragrance or one scent that you
know the same thing if one fragrance
doesn't quite do the job for you pick
another one um and and and i'm pretty
sure you'll find something that both
makes you smell good and makes you smell
the way that you want to smell and you
can if you mix and match you get coconut
vanilla citrus and herbal musk musk
lavender and rose you can build your own
personalized product bundle mix and
match through your favorite scents and
keep them on rotations you have
something for every occasion so listen
stay fresh and stay clean
a little outcast love um with native by
going to nativedeo.com
fat man we use the promo code fat men at
checkout get 20 off your first order
that's nativedeo.com
fat man we use the promo code fat man at
checkout for 20 off your first order
don't be stupid be a smartie get some
native deo in your body
i made a new rhyme
i'm a rallying fool
um
so i feel i feel pretty good i i just
did an ad read without without uh
and we would blaze through it this is
not gonna be the ad read show um
so i feel i feel pretty strong about
that and the other thing that i feel
pretty strong about
is that spider-man no way from home
trailer which dropped officially today
on august 24th unofficially on monday
the 23rd
you probably could have found it all
over the internet
as as sony and marvel played
whack-a-mole with various leaks in
century that appeared all over the place
um
you know
for me
like the the the hurdle of this movie is
that i think we all you and me and
everybody else out there who's a nerd
knows more about this movie than they
might like to we kind of know that it's
a multiversal thing we kind of know
um
that at the very least you know alfred
molina is back as doc um so if we hadn't
known that seeing him would have been a
shock and a
wonder and an awe
we knew that dr strange is in this movie
um there have been rumored other things
that that take place
namely previous spider-man's previous
mary jane's perhaps previous lots of
other things
um
so
it's it's it's good to just roll around
in that world again it's good to see tom
holland a spider-man again it's good to
see zendaya again like it's good it's
good to it's good to be back um
i'm i'm curious about doctor strange at
least the way he's presented in this
trailer because
he seems to be awfully interested in
playing fast and loose with the rules of
sort of multiversity and dimensionality
and
the perils of using magic to alter
timelines
given how much he's learned over the
past whatever three movies about the
perils of timelines
um
and so his willingness to just dive in
and monkey with the nature of reality so
that one kid can maybe not feel so weird
in the world anymore
it seems both off brand or off model but
also kind of in line with
it feels like like the absence of tony
stark has been felt very much so and the
insertion of doctor strange as now the
older mentor
to peter parker tony stark was all about
doing the wrong thing he's all about
overreach he's all about i mean he's the
dude who created ultron right like
because he thought that he knew better
than everybody else um
the the arc of tony stark's character
was ultimately going from the guy who
would snip the wire to the guy
who falls on the wire to save his
friends
and so that selfishness sort of fades
away as you get to actual like full-on
magnanimity
um
but so we're not sure where we are in
the dr strange version of that timeline
and also it might be worth saying we
don't know if that's actually dr strange
um
because he's wearing sweatpants and i'm
not sure how you feel about this but
i don't want doctors
practicing on anybody wearing sweatpants
unless it's an emergency situation this
does not feel like an emergency
so uh but but it is worth maybe thinking
about that that might not actually be
doctor strange um it could be a number
of different people um but if we're
starting to deal with magic and
multiverses and
various you know not to say that there's
interdimensional conquerors happening
yet but
there are magical bad guys that have
been rumored to have appeared or going
to appear
um as far back as one division who may
be uh choosing now as their moment to
take their to make their own trade to
the stage so
um i mean of course i'm here for it i'm
i've always loved tom holland's
interpretation of it i love i love the
vibe of all of the spider-man movies um
i do still sort of long for there to
just be like an amazing spider-man movie
where he's just your friendly
neighborhood spider-man who just
solves new york [ __ ] but
um that said
enticing enough i'll be there in
december of course i will are we kidding
um
the next thing that is a little bit
older but still more recent than justice
league
is the suicide squad
is uh is james gunn's
sequel
reboot um call it what you will of of
david ayer's previous suicide squad
movie
um
i i don't remember if if kevin has gone
on record saying what he thought of it i
i didn't say very much other than
um my love for uh david the small chin's
polka dot
man which i do think is the is the most
empathetic character in the movie i'm a
bad guy to be sure i mean they're all
bad guys um and there's no redeeming him
but
um the the thing that i struggled with
in in suicide squad
was unlike
other james gunn's movies specifically
guardians of the galaxy which is you can
you can kind of feel as if guardians of
the galaxy have been a proof of concept
that this is a guy who knows how to tell
stories superhero stories with a big
cast and still give you
that sense of of fun
and of joy but of deep character
motivations to understand it you know
like we we we understand the core trauma
of peter quill we know what his wound is
right that he's been stolen from his
home he has no connection to where he
wants to be and the only the only
tethers that he has to to his home and
to his mother that he was ripped from
uh exists in a walkman that he listens
to incessantly to make him feel better
um and his arc is from not leading that
and forming bonds with the people along
the way with the fellow guardians of the
galaxy that's his emotional arc
that makes sense and and you dig into it
and you have empathy for that guy you
have pathos for that guy uh but more
than that you kind of want that guy to
win
whereas i was i was missing that a
little bit in suicide squad because
yes they're all the worst of the worst
and they're all awful people um
you know i guess maybe we want to be
rooting for harley quinn
um
although i wish we were rooting for her
to do something other than deal with
romantic entanglements i wish that that
we could find another speed for harley
that is not about the men in her life or
the absence of men in her life and her
finding a way to push forward it felt
like the birds of prey movie um
dealt with that relatively well
um and so i just wanted more for her
because of course she's got to have her
thing it's friggin margot robbie it's
harley quinn
um she is the marquee character and
in fact if not a name
so i just wanted more to dig in with her
um i kind of loved um blood sport even
though it
did seem kind of clear that that
character was like well are we getting
will smith back no
who else do we have who's got a uh you
know father-daughter story who's also an
assassin who can also shoot anything
that moves and it's also a black dude um
and it seems as if they just went down
the thousands of characters dc has and
found the one that fits that bill
um
but idris elba
his
everything about him in that role is
hilarious and fun and like i mentioned
on twitter he's he's the roy kent of the
uh for the suicide squad and i think
that that's and and if that should tell
you why i like their characters because
i love [ __ ] roy campbell or he can't
just one one of the 21st century's great
characters on television or movies so
um yeah like i just i i i just wanted it
to be a little bit richer um it's super
gory and i love it i love that they went
for the hard r um
you know but i just i just wish it had a
little bit more um
sort of an emotional thrust to the
middle of it um at its core that wasn't
quite so
um
let me say throw away because i think
they they did do some good work with rat
catcher too and with
with you know
um polka dot man and with blood sport um
and i thought that parts of it were very
funny although i was hoping that i'd be
laughing more throughout it um all that
said um i'm i'm 100 here for more
suicide squad i think much of this cast
is great
um i think they
they ended it in such a place where you
can come back with the ones that you
liked and keep on going
and uh you know take money on who
survives the third movie
um
but yeah so i'm i'm i i'm curious to
know
um
what uh what you guys thought about it
and i'm also curious to know how
you know there was a lot of conversation
about how
um
you know it made
i think 26 million some odd dollars it's
opening weekend which seems as if it was
presented as a flop
but free guy makes the same exact amount
of money the same weekend but that's a
hit um so the the industry perception of
what
the suicide squad did compared to other
movies compared to what the first one
did because the first one was a
blockbuster the first one was a legit
hit
you made 750 million worldwide there's
nothing to sneeze at which is why of
course you got a second one um but i
just wonder what given the times we're
living in giving the the
delta variant just squashing what had
been a resurgent box office
if all of that is meaning we are maybe
not as excited about a third one as we
might have been before this open so
i hope that's not the case because i'd
like to see more um and and i'd like to
just be able to zero in on sort of what
makes these guys special and what makes
it fun
um
so yeah that is that is suicide squad um
very quickly i can't remember
if kevin and i talked about what if
um because again time time is a flat
circle and it's getting flatter and
circlier every day that we go on
um i i
but to encapsulate at least my feelings
about it at the moment i i was i was i
liked the first episode
captain carter um
even even though it occasionally got a
little bit too
um
i knew what it was doing almost all the
time you know it's
it was very much what if what if captain
carter got the super soldiers here from
steve
and so then the plot ended up following
very closely the beats of the first
avenger
and so there were a couple there were
surprises there to be sure there were
there were twists on on the the story as
we know it different characters are
slotted in
you know steve rogers has his own
version of that story um
and so you know it's fun to see that the
variances and the different ways that um
that you can twist that story but
ultimately they were telling the story
that we
you know we knew we
get to the point where there's gonna be
there's gonna be some sort of thing that
separates you know peggy and steve
there's going to be a loss there's going
to be somebody falls off a train there's
going to be
um you know red skull is going to do red
skull [ __ ] um
and so
you know it it and there was going to be
some time displacement so that the
captain the person with the shield would
be separated from the person that they
loved i mean you thought that that was
going to happen how they did it was new
and interesting but
um
there was a little bit of a road map to
follow
where's the second episode
um which again similarly like starts
from the same kernel of like all right
well what if instead of picking up peter
quill
um on earth uh the the yondu and the
ravages picked up t'challa who was like
wandering outside of the of the the
wakandan safety shield
and uh and says he wants to be an
adventurer and wants to go on adventure
and then what happens to
the guardians of the galaxy as we know
them if it's not
um peter quill but instead you know a
boy born to be a king
and i felt like they took way more
liberties like they didn't have a
specific story
that they needed to
to sort of map that on to
so they had more more ways to go with it
and more interesting things
at least to me to explore with it namely
what happens to the universe if a good
man
um
is at the center of uh
of what had been is basically robin hood
like what happens if you turn this this
gang of thieves and and and murderers
and ravagers into the force for good you
know what happens to the universe if
somebody like t'challa um is operating
on the fringes of it
what happens to yondu and thanos and all
those characters um
and not only that the story they were
telling could be a brand new story like
they could tell what is ultimately a
heist story um
which was a ton of fun you know like i i
think that when the water stories are
going to succeed and we'll see there's
going to be you know a bunch more and
there's a whole second season to
greenlit
you know so far it seems like they find
the most success
when they are inspired by that change to
go off and change more things about the
story as opposed to leaning and hewing
too close to what we already accept as
narrative
you know and as we skip through the
phases like this seems to be a phase one
story or a phase two story and as we
start getting into three and four
um
how they choose to define the stories
they want to tell and the liberties
they're gonna take will dictate to a
great degree um how successful they are
at it
so um
but it's also [ __ ] gorgeous i mean
uh i i
we've all seen
different varying kinds of animations
you know from the kind of hand-drawn
lushness of miyazaki
and and studio ghibli all the way to
pixar and everything in between
but you know this feels somewhat unique
to me there's there's a level of texture
and color and lighting specifically the
lighting is so beautiful um
that it feels new and and even though a
lot of it is cg and that can
occasionally be a stunning block for the
voice acting
um it uh it it
they it's not quite as awful as i'd seen
it in the past like i think they're
cracking some code to figure out how to
make
the the cg animated mouth movements feel
more organic that's always the problem
they don't quite feel organic
um
and you know it's
in trying to analyze especially the
t'challa episode
divorcing yourself a little bit from the
emotional reaction that i know that i
had and i think lots of other people had
to the fact that it's chadwick boseman
the fact that this is the last time we
get to see him
um
performing as as t'challa
and
and there's there's no discounting the
amount of of
you know heft that that adds to it and
it's also a funny performance and it's
comic it is his timing is so on point
um
you know not to say that that
getting getting haley out well back as
as as peggy carter is not great not to
say that getting you know a lot of the
howlers back isn't great not to say that
getting all of the the ravages back
isn't great
um you know and and it seems as a marvel
animation you know that there's
there's no expense there's spared no
expense in getting as many of the the og
players back as they can
but you know there's always something
incredibly profoundly moving about a
swan song and so
there's there's you know extra bonus
points
for the for the chadwick boseman of it
all um
so yeah i think that that kind of gets
us up to date
i think with with some of the more
recent stuff that we would have talked
about on fatman beyond if kev was here
um
you know yeah no way no no way home
trailer suicide squad what if
um
the news
there's been some interesting stuff but
not so
tectonic that that it was worth a
special edition to cover
um but i think that
you know we uh it might be time to get
into the main course
it might be time to dig in um it might
be time to uh
to to to unite the seven
which is a tagline that they started for
the justice league and then abandoned
once i guess they realized that they
were not gonna have a martial manhunter
in the original justice league and then
it was only six people but there had
been posters uh i'm sure you remember um
if you if you were died in the
wilderness the way i am and who pays
attention to marketing campaigns the way
i do which i hope you're not that person
i hope there's more
there's more to this provincial life
than just uh tracking poster changes and
campaign adjustments um but at any rate
we now do get seven
um
in in zack steiner's justice league
but before we do that
i promised you that there was another ad
um it might have even been a threat
depending on on your your point of view
um but no we do have another another ad
and they had the second ad of this
episode is for
keeps we've talked about keeps before we
talked about how um you know both kevin
and i have had our follicle challenges
um i'm i'm i'm combating it with um
uh barbering techniques
namely keeping my hair so short you
don't notice the hair that's not there
um kevin combats his with uh hats
which is a very valid way to go um
about two out of three men in in the u.s
if not the world will experience some
form of hair loss by the time they're 35
um and that that amounts to maybe
somewhere around like 50 million guys in
the
u.s there are only two fda approved
medications that can help prevent hair
loss and keeps offers them both a simple
stress-free way to keep your hair a
convenient virtual doctor consultations
medications delivered straight to your
door every three months you don't have
to leave your house
and the way things are going
maybe not leaving your house is not the
worst thing in the world to do
um
since low cost treatments start at just
ten dollars a month uh keeps offers
genetic generic versions of the of their
treatments and discrete packaging proven
results they have more five-star reviews
than any of their competitors and
prevention is the key i mean you know
kevin i've talked about it before keeps
always mentions it
that treatments can take four to six
months to see results you know it's not
going to bring back hair that's already
gone but it'll keep keep the hair you
have that's what's important so act now
and if you're ready to take action
prevent hair loss go to keps.com
fat man to receive your first month of
treatment for free that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash fat man to give your first
month free keeps.com
keeps keeps keep the hair
the hair that's up there or by supposing
the hair anywhere that you would like to
hold on to keeps.com slash fat man
first month free see how it works out
for you get that hair back get get that
samson strength son
samson strength
okay
i'm feeling
strong i feel pretty good i uh
i wasn't sure we'd ever get here boys
and girls i wasn't sure that the
technology would be possible um or one's
will would be strong enough but it is
um so let's talk about the justice
league let's talk about zack snyder's
justice league and i will tell you
um
uh we are not going to
this isn't like all right we're going to
start the logo and we're going to go
through it it's not going to be four
hours long nor is it not going to be a
minute and a half long because when i
did go back to it
and look at it with you know i widened
my gaze
and uh and there was quite a bit that i
found in there that was worth talking
about and and was noteworthy
um
chief among them being
you know zack snyder
directs action with the best of them um
it's
you always the thing about action movies
the thing about action direction the
thing about that cinematography
is the easiest way to go awry is to be
so frenetic with the camera and so kind
of willingly with your editing
to attempt to convey a feeling of action
through frenzy
right through energy um it can sometimes
and by sometimes we very often result in
a confusing movie because the the way it
works the way it works clearest for an
audience is if they know where they are
if they know what's happening if they
know where characters are in relation to
each other
you know not that this needs to be
a martial arts movie um and there are
plenty of bad versions of martial arts
movies where there's just punches and
kicks happening but you can't really
tell who's throwing them and who's
getting hit whatever
you know jackie chan you know inspired
very much by old like mgm musicals was
in the forefront of just locking the
camera down everything is immediate to
wide shots so that you see what's
happening
so that you can see the dance action
scenes are always dance their
choreography
and the only way it works is if you can
understand what's happening and so zack
snyder is a very muscular filmmaker and
that the camera is always moving and the
camera is always you know pushing and
pulling and sweeping but you're never
lost in the scenes and then that is no
small thing um and so and with a
four-hour long movie there's a ton of
action there
and you you never you never find
yourself confused by what's happening he
does not he does not sacrifice clarity
for for action for frenzy
um
and so i've always responded to that in
his work you know as far back as dawn of
the dead
you know even through movies that that i
like even less than than than some of
others um
this was never his problem
um this was never a failing of his it
was always very clear that he he planned
all these shots out he worked with the
summer towers he blocked it he
talking to his actives and making sure
that everything felt as if they they had
a purpose to be happy
that every every character in the screen
was in exactly where he wanted them to
be so that an audience can kind of sit
back and take it all in and there's a
ton of visual information and if you
can't organize it well then it just
turns into you know weird action soup
so
that is number one
number two
um steppenwolf
has a much cooler design in this version
um i feel like you know that
from the the original theatrical cut to
this
it's ornate and complicated and
intricate but it's it's a thousand
degrees more interesting
than it was before um and not only does
he does he feel um
a more fully realized version on the
screen his motivations are clearer um
you know we we talk about that all the
time in this podcast when we're talking
about movies the idea that
you know the audience has to at least
have a clear understanding of what the
character thinks he wants
it doesn't always have to be true the
truth of what he does want
because you know especially when you're
dealing with humans
who are who have their own series of
issues and their own series of
misgivings and shortcomings
oftentimes we don't know what we want
even while we're doing the stuff we're
doing
that is just delusion and humans engage
in delusion all the time
you know um
uh
brad pitt's character in seven
thinks that he wants a family
and he's moved to this this city and
he's got his wife with him and they just
want to have a child and but he's
operating as if
that's not on his agenda because he
wants to actually be a fantastic
detective
there's the things we tell ourselves
that we think are true and there's the
things that are true
and so motivation is very important and
the the audience is understanding what
those motivations are it's also crucial
and so now i get what
what steppenwolf is doing i get what
he's after he wants he wants approval
from dad right like dark seed is dead
dark side i keep wanting to say seed
but i feel like dark side is cool but
dark seed is also very cool
you know this is what happens when um a
character exists for most of your life
only on the page and you are the only
person who's ever said it out loud
um but dark side i get it but so dark
side is daddy there's a granny goodness
there's there's desaa there's all these
things but dark side is daddy and
steppenwolf was a bad boy and [ __ ] his
[ __ ] up and now he wants daddy to
approve
it's it's it's a very elemental
emotional desire which is i want dad to
be proud of me and so i'm going to do
things that will make dad proud of me
and once you've used that lens which is
a much clearer lens in this edition um
what he's doing and why he's doing it
completely makes sense
number three
more joe morton is always better
joe morton is one of america's great
living actors um
routinely unheralded and un-championed
for his work but he has been
fantastic for decades
everything he's in is better because
he's in it um
so the fact that this version of the
film has a load more joe morton in it i
will 100 take it um
i uh i i had i must have mentioned this
on twitter at some point but i always
wanted to write like a short story just
called um
miles bennett dyson's bad day
um which is just about his character in
terminator 2 who woke up that morning
thinking that everything was going to be
great right like
i'm going to go to work i'm going to
keep on working on the terminator [ __ ]
i'm gonna crack it finally i'm gonna get
close and we're gonna figure out how to
crack the ai and make ai functional
thing and then we can we can make skynet
happen we can make all of this
all of this can be ours
i just need a couple more good days of
working with this stuff
and then you know a terminator crashes
into his life and ruins everything um
and that terminator is not on
schwarzenegger but
that is not a hero there
this version of cyborg
um
and this version of
of both silas um
and his son
are much deeper
you know than they had been before and
the thing that i that i didn't quite get
the first time around
um
but watching it again
this version of cyborg is frightening
um the the
his power balance is almost off the
charts because
the idea that he can he he has mastery
over everything at work in a connected
universe right like
um everything is from as big to nuclear
arsenals to as small as power grids
which are not small
two is as precise as financial systems
anything that is connected by anything
resembling wire is his to play with
and that is a dude
who is
functionally
the most powerful person on the planet
right like yeah no superman could punch
things through you know can can lift
buildings in a single bound and can you
know punch through time and space and
whatever
but that guy
like if batman's superpower is that he's
rich
this guy can absolve all of that wealth
like with a snap of his fingers
you know
he could he could destroy lives and
shift continents and alter
the very fabric of the world that we
know
because he's decided to one day
um
and granted this movie doesn't actually
let you you play that much with those
powers that he has because they're used
to make him fly around a bunch [ __ ] but
you know i kept finding myself i'm like
this is a a really smart
reinterpretation of this character
um and it's putting all of these things
on on front street about the things that
he can and cannot do and the reasons why
he's now
[Music]
really really powerful not special the
reasons why we're special um existed
before he he gets power but
i did keep finding myself wanting
a little bit more of that because i
thought that was a fantastic idea
um
number number four i didn't number these
so i'm just going to remember i'm going
to hope i remember what number
remember number one was about how zack
snyder directs action with the best of
them
the flashback war against darkseid is
awesome
um
you know like [ __ ] just
i could watch that [ __ ] all day you know
introducing prehistoric you know a
prehis well no prehistoric yeah that
works prehistory is legendary it's a
myth
fallen green lanterns and greek gods and
men and atlanteans and everybody's
fighting on the same playing field and
he's a big ass bad guy that's his ass
kicked
um
it's awesome i mean it's it's
it is all um
the side of a van
and uh and if you grew up in a place in
a time in which dudes have panel bands
that they would airbrush these these uh
like heavy metal inspired fantasy
dioramas onto the sides of them that's
what this feels like
um it feels like you know some boris
vallejo uh album cover for like bad out
of hell come to life
uh it's it's just it's it's mind-blowing
and it's epic and it's it you know it
it is all flashback it's not front story
it's backstory but still as a as a piece
to look at
it's unbelievable
um number five
this scene i don't think it changed too
much in in the in the two iterations um
the theatrical cut and the center cut
but i found the scene
when uh bruce wayne recruits barry allen
um to be uh both fun
because it's it's witty it's funny
um
because i think ben is doing some really
smart straight man work and i think that
ezra miller is kind of going for it but
all that stuff comes out of character
right it comes out of a kid
who is incredibly lonely comes out of a
an older guy
who
um
he's already failed trying to recruit
arthur curry and needs a win
you know and he just he's impressing
upon this kid with um money and cool and
gadgets and this wickedness [ __ ]
mercedes benz all of it
is is all in service of making barry
allen believe that he could be batman
and not and more than that believe that
even bruce wayne is [ __ ] cool as [ __ ]
and i think that that scene
you know 100 sells that um
and it's a good time and it's just it's
it's it's fun and it's funny and i feel
like the this even this version of it
even though
um
i'm not even gonna say it because
remember this is the bright side so i
will just say that um
that there there's there's more humor in
this movie than i remember there being
and this is this scene is very
emblematic of that
um
flash saving civilians from falling
rocks i thought was great because you
know the the visualization of how
flash's powers works tends to go two
ways right you either slow it all the
way down
you under crank it so then he's just
like swimming through the air but other
things are not moving around it but
there's lots of lightning [ __ ] happening
or you speed it all the way up
and then you get the you know just the
blur that's happening in the world
um
i felt like that scene was a good
synthesis of the two because you get the
the you know
the man moving so fast that everything
slows down but then you also get the
vantage point of your bystander civilian
who's just seeing the world shift and
lightning flash and [ __ ] just happen um
so i thought that was that was a really
nice distillation of both of those
versions of it
um
i think that jason momoa is giving this
is the next point whatever number this
is
he's giving a more interesting
performance here um because he's
he's he's actually playing
the outsider
more than he had been before you know
he's he's a guy who's separated from
both um the dry world and the wet world
and so you know watching the stuff with
mira watching the stuff with with willem
dafoe you know you're sensing his
separation from that world
um but you're also sensing a longing for
that world you sense a longing for for a
place to belong
and so that is what he's responding to i
think
um not just you know stepping over
showing up you know stealing boxes and
[ __ ] but the idea that he could belong
in the justice league um is something
that you know sometimes isn't on the
page all the time but i think it's
always in mahala's performance
and uh and there's a real gravity to him
you know which is a thing that hadn't
been played before he in the fiance cut
there's a there's a weird surfer bro
about aquaman but in here there's a real
heaviness to that character um and a lot
of it is performance a lot of that is
just mama kind of giving looks and
taking up space on the screen and
his skepticism is real here in a way
that it wasn't quite as tangible as it
needed to be before
um and so yeah i found myself responding
a bit more to what he was doing i mean
the aquaman movie would would
find a way to ride that balance between
you know um
aquatic yahoo and and tortured x you
know excommunicated prints um but i
think it's it's just it's a little bit
heavier here and i think i like it more
um
i still do love this bit it survived in
both versions of the film when uh when
you know angry clark comes out of the
whatever you know the the the dead grave
sarcophagus thingy whatever and you know
it's it's your your heroes are fighting
your other hero who's lost his mind
right and so that's always cool and
that's always fun
um
but it's just that look
that uh that clark gives to barry when
barry's running by him
and you know he's holding he's got
aquaman in one arm and and uh and and
diane in another arm and he's like you
know whatever holding him off then it's
just a little like
a little look to the side
that shows that tells barry that oh [ __ ]
not only is he strong not only does he
have [ __ ] laser eye beams um not only
is he like beautiful
um but he's as fast as i am and he can
see me when nobody else can see me um
it's it's those little
you know surprises in those scenes
that that a they knew to write in the
script b they needed to shoot and
preserve
um
it's i i do love that moment quite a bit
i also love the fact
that almost every time
you see barry allen in any scene
he has this wide-eyed look of delight
you know like it seems as if that that
character could always be
the the person for whom this is all new
um he he does not have any superhero
friends besides these guys he has not
done any superheroic [ __ ] before this
stuff
but there's this wide-eyed
just glee
on his face almost every scene he walks
into
you know and it's
it's a little bit to the left i think of
most interpretations of barry allen
you know you know grant gustin plays him
you know even in the beginning was not
quite this um
you know googly-eyed
um
you know the comics have you know there
have been various interpretations
needless to say the characters you know
more than 50 years old and lots of
people have their their chance of
writing it so it always shifts but
um
it's not out of character what israe
miller is doing it's bigger
um it's it's and it's not quite
caricature either but there is this
it is not insignificant around a
character who finds all of this
wonderful
um and awesome
by the dictionary definition of awe so
some of this is awe you're filled with
just i've never seen this before
um and so i really did appreciate that
about his performance um
i think the uh the final push uh against
steppenwolf when
the league is together waiting for
superman to show up which you know is
gonna happen um
you know the the final assault on
steppenwolf in that abandoned russian
city is much cleaner the action is
staged better um the skies are not as
red and fiery and and you know filled
with goop as it was before
and uh the lack of that annoying russian
family
um that nobody ever gave a [ __ ] about
anyway
um is is appreciated
because yeah that just seemed to be
business that was answering some note of
what are the stakes
of of this final battle who's can we put
somebody on the ground for whom this is
everything
and they just cluttered everything up it
just it muddied the waters
uh if we don't understand by now
that
that all of the things that steppenwolf
is doing and all the things that dark
side will do
if the unity is achieved and the mother
boxes bring them forth and all that
stuff
then adding three people we don't give a
[ __ ] about is not gonna do that
so this is much clearer and cleaner
and um
and and the action stays better
um
i did like
you know the the
a couple of little easter eggs and
they're maybe really easter eggs but
they're just they're they're kicks
forward
to the movies we
probably will not get to see
which is the ryan choi set up as the
atom in in star labs i thought that was
that was pretty well done and it's a
very short story there's like three or
four scenes that help set up that thing
um and then after silas sacrifices
himself he's going to take over star
labs like that's cool
um
and i dug the the death stroke reveal um
you know i feel like
that's that is a character who who
gets to play on the same playing field
as batman
and in the same sort of power levels
like that is not a superman villain um
you know or a wonder woman but it's a
batman villain and i think that that
introducing that character
um
and and joe manganiello as that
character i thought was pretty smart
um
so yeah like i uh that's that's the end
of my list fyi
which i don't think was insignificant
i think people somewhat expected this
review to be like and credits and also
the music wasn't bad um
you know looking at it again there was
there was quite a bit that i responded
to
but you know and and as i i'm trying to
be a person in my word and i'm not
i am not uh losing an uncivil tongue
um towards it um i've done that before
don't need to do it again
um
but but yeah there you have it that's
the bright side of you um those are the
things that i that i liked those are
things i respond those are the choices
that i thought worked
um
uh jc is there any is there any feeling
from the crowd one way or another
um
yeah i think people pretty much agreed
with you in uh in chat we had some
people wondering if we were gonna do
some q and a's but i didn't get really
any q and a's i did have people uh have
you seen the star wars visions trailer
i did see the star wars visions trailer
questions about that
yeah no and i thought it's fantastic i
mean it
it um you know it's it's
i i i love it because
i don't know if it's canon or not and i
also don't really care
but the idea that
people process stories in different ways
based upon um
their the places they live their
cultural environment how they were
raised their own content that they
ingest and make
and sort of watch star wars through the
prism of a different culture
and in a very real way the culture that
star wars itself came out of because
lucas has gone on record and i think
it's no surprise to anybody that you
know hidden fortress the cure course i
was having fortress was direct
inspiration
on on the star wars and the plot and
some of the characters but also even you
know the the costuming and i mean the
lightsabers are just katanas that glow
and all of that stuff is baked into what
star wars is and so to
to return to the culture that inspired
star wars and then giving them license
to do whatever they want with it
you know i just feel like that's
interesting i don't know if it's all
going to work um
you know it reminds me a bit of like the
animatrix the the experiment that the
wachowskis and warner brothers did were
they just like yeah here's this giant ip
which is very much based on our love for
for asian cinema go to town
guys
and some of those shorts were phenomenal
some of them were a little bit up their
own ass but i think that that's the
the the highs of the high sort of make
the lows of the load worth it um
and i would much rather watch people
swing big [ __ ] swings
at uh at a world and maybe fail
then not take those big swings at all so
i can't wait to see it you know and and
there's already a couple of ideas that
i'm so surprised we hadn't seen before
namely um the weird lightsaber umbrella
i thought was [ __ ] rad
um
so yeah i can't wait for that
yeah i think it looks neat like how many
more times do we want to see a canon
story with a jedi that does something i
think this looks really cool
yeah um we did get a couple questions uh
the first one an update on splinter
yes i should have given that in the uh
how we got here
portion um
splinter is proceeding a pace we are
closing in on some of our final
outstanding department heads um
and uh and if you know the the use of
the phrase department heads means
basically
that to make a movie there's a bunch of
different
people and roles that need to be filled
there's picture which the department
head for pictures is a cinematographer
there's um
sort of construction meaning the
physical space that you're shooting it
in and that department has a production
designer there is sound
and that production is the head is the
sound designer there's the editor on the
back end for post production there's
special effects there's all that stuff
and so we're beginning to zero in
on
the production heads that we need
for physical to shoot it
um
you know there's the production and the
post production phase so post-production
is you know music and special effects
and editorial and uh and and also the
post-production sound
design mixing and recording and stuff
like that
so we're focusing very heavily on the
front end of it so that we can have it
in the can um but even still there's
some some people that we've targeted and
engaged to do some that back-end stuff
as well
so the hope is still to shoot in early
november um the the sound stage slash
location that we need is available in
that time and we have a hold on it
um and so things are things are going
somehow both faster and slower than i'd
like um which means it's going at about
the pace it should
at least that's that's what my producing
partners tell me
so it uh it is all looking good we have
a couple roles left to cast but you know
that that was always going to be a thing
that was the biggest juggling
act
in that you know much of our cast are
are both friends but professionals and
they got [ __ ] that needs to get done in
the world they've got jobs they've got
to do and so making sure that
everybody's free for the same like five
days in november is uh is the is the
hurdle we need to leave but i feel like
we're gonna get that done
and uh and yeah it's exciting and and
nerve-wracking and petrifying
uh especially when i spent a little bit
of time in new jersey on the set of
another um small indie film
and just watching the sheer number of
people all going to work
you know
rowing in the same direction
that's the miracle of a film set is that
everybody knows what they're supposed to
be doing
at any given time everybody's a freaking
professional and amazing at their job
and then watching a
film crew kick into gear
um is is really a joy to behold and so
you know the the the idea that that
we're gonna get to do that for ourselves
to hire a crew that is as dedicated as
as as i am to it and then watching them
you know do the work that they do and
make the art that they make is really
what i'm looking forward to so yeah no
we're we're uh we're cruising i think
and hopefully there are no icebergs
waiting for us on this wee little baby
ship
uh this i thought was an appropriate
question from torres88
do you think after you finish your own
film you will change
uh how you critique things or will it
have no effect seeing as how this is the
uh the bright version of the justice
league
um
i
i think the lesson that people learn
when they when they go from talking
about things to making things
is an appreciation for how hard it is to
make anything good
um
i
i have already made that turn i think
because i know that that nobody sets out
to make a bad movie
um
and and it's it's incredibly hard to see
when you're in the middle of it
um you know nobody sets out to to write
a bad script nobody sets out to write it
back season of tv nobody sets out to
make anything that people don't like
um
it takes the same amount of work to do
and so and i have so much respect for
anybody who gets to do it um
and so part of the reasons why
um when i when i do critique things when
i do analyze things
it is never from a place of i hate that
filmmaker i think this is [ __ ]
um
this was all a waste of time because i
know that it's not because i know that
that that everybody goes into these
things with the best of intentions and
they bring all of their talent to bear
to make it and there are a thousand
reasons why
um it's it's that it's the doctor
strange thing right like there's 14
million ways for us to fail but there's
one way for us to succeed
and you know there's a there's hundreds
of ways for any movie to go wrong but to
find the one path to make a great thing
um
is a worth celebrating and
to also try and figure out those
hundreds of ways that it could go wrong
so that at least for me when i start
writing and when i start you know knock
on wood directing stuff
um i will maybe have answered some of
those questions i might have gone down
some of those roads and found out where
they had no purchase on the other side
that there was no fertile ground
um so i i don't think so because i do
have i've already got that respect for
the people who do it and manage to get
it done
um i think i feel like that's the lesson
that people learn when they go from
being an amateur to a professional um
and and luckily
you know
i i
have been able to make that to bridge
that gap already
um
but i think i will have a better
appreciation for how exhausted people
are after they make movies
um
because i know you know talking to kevin
i was like hey man whenever you're back
we can jump right into it and also fully
realizing he's gonna need like a week or
two just to put his brain back together
um
get his mind right and uh and go to
[ __ ] sleep for a while because it is
an all-encompassing task to do at length
so
so yeah i feel like i feel like that's
what i'm going to take away from it it's
just the physical toll it takes
um and then the amount of goodwill that
you have to you have to have for people
to spend on you to give them your time
even if you're giving them money it is
uh it is no small thing to ask for
so yeah
yes yes yes yes yes yes and no
um let's see uh matt kilbane was
interested uh what if anything will you
take from justice league and incorporate
into splinter
um
you know like i think that the the trick
about splinter
is is sh
much of it takes place on a plane
and so it's it's shooting confined
spaces
and making them feel um
make them feel like they've gotten more
to them than just the the square footage
right it's
it's finding new ways to keep shooting
in the same space um justice league did
not do very much of that
um because just at least a big ass movie
that never really felt confined anywhere
um but i think a lot of it is to do with
um
it's all clarity and i feel like when
you know the many of the moments that i
that i mentioned in the review
we're about clarity we're about you know
when you're doing an action scene where
are all of the the actors where is the
where's the camera looking where's the
where's the audience going to focus
you know how are we going to pass
information you know how to make things
that you know may or may not feel like
regular boring scenes interesting
you know and zack snyder can do that
zach cena can make a guy walking down a
hallway
interesting by where he puts the camera
and so
i'm starting to think a lot about that
about you know staging and plot choice
and
angle choice
even things like lens choice which i'm
just starting to learn about the
difference between the various lenses
and their emotional impact
um and every movie you watch can teach
you a lesson about that um and so the
the trick for me now is just watching
movies even movies i've loved for years
with that different perspective
um
i found um
stephen soderbergh has this you know
ultimately it's his own website which i
think he had been using over the over
the years as you know both a weird
little classroom where he would talk
about things and post them
um and a blog
functioning as a blog does but he had
this this whole entry about staging
which is um you know where actors are in
the screen and on the stage um
and how specifically stephen spielberg
is so fantastic at it
and so he what he did was
he's like i i i turned on rate as the
lost ark which you know has all of the
things that you know every movie needs
to have which is you know action and
suspense and humor and
and and romance and all of it um but
he's like spielberg has forgotten more
about staging than i'll ever know
so what i wanted to do was look at
raiders and only focus on that
so he pulled all the color out of it he
transferred into a black and white movie
and then he pulled all of the sound out
of it and just added in i want to say
that it's the the the uh trent reznor
atticus ross score for um social network
and so you're just watching shapes on
screen
and yes it helps that i've seen that
movie like 50 times and so i know what's
happening in each scene
but also i don't feel like any of it's
confusing um the way characters are
moving the way the camera is following
them the things the camera's focusing on
the way he uses things like depth of
field and soft focus and deep focus and
all of that stuff to help tell that
story
it's phenomenal it's like a master class
and so if you if you look up stephen
soderbergh rey is a lost ark you can
find that page and you can watch that
movie
um it only lives on his page because to
give that away would be like stealing
and
bastardizing somebody else's art
but i think it's really really it's like
a clinic on how to do that work
so so that's what i've been doing a lot
of you know especially as we get you
know months away from from rolling is
just figuring out
my own version of cinematic language
um
and trying to make things like clarity
and staging as clear and staged as they
can't be
all right i think i got one more for you
from
[Music]
i butchered that name i apologize
um
if you got to set a story in the avatar
the last airbender world which element
would you prefer to write it around
i thought you were an avatar fan weren't
you i am an avatar fan
that is a fantastic question
um
i mean one of my favorite characters is
tough
and so the earth bending kingdom is
really interesting
fire feels too easy because fire always
feels like it's it's about power
in a way that the other words aren't
um because fire is the most
openly and and obviously destructive
version of that
but
there's something about about earth
bending that's interesting to me
from a
um
yeah just it's
there's something so
so
you do not think
of all of the elements
earth does not seem to be the one
that is the most operative right like
yes until you see it at work until you
see people making things out of rock and
pillars and
armor and all that stuff it's not it's
not flying like wind it's not in damage
like fire it's not um pressure like
water it's earth which feels inert
naturally but to to transform that into
into motion and action
is really interesting um
so yeah i think i think i think it's
it's a it's a it's a bossing say story
probably it's an earth it's an earth
bending story
um
yeah no that's a good question i've
never thought about that before
um
because nobody's asked me to write an
avatar story
um but it would be fun and i think
that's where i that's where i'd lean
yeah that's pretty much it um i guess
we've kind of covered this john blount
what tv show pastor present would you
want to direct
um
wow
i feel like
you know
not
there's something super fun
about tv shows set in la
or the release that's shot in la
especially back in like the 70s the 60s
70s and 80s
um
you know like i always think about like
the a team or knight rider where it's
totally clearly you're never leaving los
angeles even if it's supposed to be
texas or louisiana or tennessee or
chicago or where the hell michael knight
is writing any given week
but
car stunts fist fights the occasional
shootout
you know um
yeah it's [ __ ] night rider i think
um
you know it it reminds me a bit of like
you know
not to continue to conscious steven
spielberg but like that dude did a [ __ ]
a ton of of just like colombos and night
galleries and
you know whatever the hell was shooting
on the universe a lot at the time like
he at 19 and 20 and 21 years old was
directed to television
and
it's the and you can still if you look
at those you can still see and you can
tell the difference between a spielberg
one and everybody else's one because he
was just so freaking good at it and and
so to be able to come to something that
doesn't inherently have
flair and then bring some flair to it
seems like it would be fun
so uh so yeah i'm going night rider [ __ ]
yeah
all right i think that's it for
everybody asking what mark thought about
the new spider-man trailer uh watch the
beginning of the episode this episode as
soon as it ends
i think that's it for today i think
that's it for today back uh next tuesday
though live and in person
live and in person with uh
we we've threatened to try and get rahul
on once or twice before um but it's all
come together and he's also got a new
show coming on netflix soon midnight
mass we get to talk about
um i get to talk about his uh his what
seems to be painstaking model building
work
his uh his love for video games and uh
sneakers
uh yeah we're gonna have a good old time
and we're gonna be in a bar with people
um and we're all gonna be vast and
should you choose to want to attend live
you two will need to be baxed as well
um so yes that is next
next tuesday the 31st of august at the
scumbag cantina um tickets are on sale
um
um
yeah i mean it's smodcast.com we'll have
them you can hit up my twitter you can
hit up you know jc and the cement that's
coming with any account that'll tell you
where to go um
but
have you had a good time tonight
yeah
[Music]
um well
that is in great part thanks to the guy
who's not in my left but actually 3000
miles away new jersey
who uh who built the house in which we
currently play
and uh and i will always be grateful for
him to that he did that and that he
allows me the keys when he's gone
um
and so until next week
where where black man beyond will
continue um we will see you then same
black time same black channel
smodcast.com or
youtube.com kevin smith
you